toute la journée au domicile de la
victime trois techniciens
d'investigation criminelle ont travaillé
sur la scène de crime
la gendarmerie de cuisery avait été
appelé à une heure du matin cette nuit
une femme de 47 ans a été retrouvée
morte atteinte de plusieurs coups de
couteau
le mari et le fils de la victime ont été
entendus toute la journée par les
gendarmes
l' enquête a été confiée à la brigade de
recherches de louhans qui travaillent
sur plusieurs pistes notamment celle de
l'environnement familial le fils âgé
d'une vingtaine d'années a fait
plusieurs séjours en hôpital
psychiatrique et était connu pour
consommer de la drogue dure
des vérifications sont en cours à ce
sujet la nouvelle de ce drame a laissé
les habitants de romenay sous le choc
elle était bas et mais tout le monde
s'est testé quelqu'un remonte bien ce
que tu peux bien des enfants de l'école
ils en disent que du bien c'est a été
vraiment y mettre tout le monde et enfin
c'est vraiment peur c'est pas normal ce
qui s'est passé
la victime était donc assistantes
maternelles dans la classe de la
directrice de l'école elle s'occupait
d'une vingtaine d'élèves de grande
section
une cellule psychologique est prévue à
la rentrée en concertation avec
l'inspection d'académie pour aider ces
jeunes élèves qui viennent de perdre une
de leurs encadrante